[Music]
so
[Music]
yo what is up everyone welcome back
saturday morning we're doing some art
you know when i was growing up we were
watching cartoons on saturday morning
i feel like y'all
um i mean this isn't a world let's be
honest it's not a worldwide thing but um
we got our on saturday mornings that's
what it is now and i like it i feel like
you get both you get cartoons you get
art it's a good time it's a very
creative time saturday morning it's
chill time
um and yeah we're hopping in we're gonna
be creating art today i'm in unreal
engine five as you all know um
and we're gonna be making some cool
stuff for the moving meditations 3d
challenge
um it is a challenge a community
challenge where each of you all get a
you get the same prompt and you make it
your own you make it unique
you got one more week left one more week
left to work on your art we've gotten
hundreds of submissions so far and over
the next week they're all going to be
pouring in we have the most people
participating in this challenge with
six thousand plus i believe
submission or not submissions we have
six thousand plus people working on
their art we'll see how many people
submit this time around um but i can't
wait to see everyone's art it's gonna be
one giant martial arts mega montage
um
and yeah you know i've been working on
my art over the last few weeks here
trying to build out a scene that i'm
proud of and i've made some good
progress on it this week
and
stream wise what we'll be doing i'm
going to be overhauling my art today on
stream
i've been working on an interior
warehouse scene but i want to bring in
some exterior elements to my to my
render to my environment so i'm going to
be
busting down some walls putting in some
windows adding a city in the background
and incorporating that element to my
environment um
then i'll get more into that
once we hop in of course um i'm in
unreal engine five i know it's something
that y'all are trying to learn i'm
really trying to learn it i feel like
i've gotten a grasp on it so it feels
really nice to be able to create some
cool stuff some photo real stuff in
unreal engine 5. so hopefully y'all can
learn something as i'm learning along
the way
i will also be in cinema 4d creating
some more custom elements
these windows the walls
and then i'm going to be using kit bash
assets to
uh you know for all the background
buildings and whatnot so
before we hop in
a couple announcements first
um i'm going to be talking about some
kit bash codes we've got some discount
codes to give away there's 50 of them uh
in total
so i'll announce that uh in the next
little bit here
um
and we also have a sponsor for today's
stream they're super cool i've actually
been using their stuff for a while now
for a few years and i really enjoy it so
i always try and cater these
these sponsors
to to first to me
um i want them to be valued valuable to
myself so that they can hopefully be
valuable to y'all um
the less random the sponsor the better
um so let's hop into this one here and
i'll see you guys in about a minute stay
tuned
so i got a bunch of weird personal rules
that i live by that i've picked up over
the years and i'm gonna share two of
them with you now rule number 16 do not
buy pants unless they stretch rule
number 32 the less crap i have in my
pockets the better because i gotta be
able to move you know and the absolute
worst thing to have in your pocket is a
freaking george wallet which is why
these things are the absolute best
they're made by exeter they're the
sponsor of today's video and they make
the world's slimmest smartest wallets
extra sent me a wallet back when i
rebooted this channel and i've honestly
loved it so these wallets are super slim
which is very important to me and they
actually have this really cool quick
action level that makes taking out your
cards really satisfying but what makes
these wallets extra special are these
solar powered tracking cards so if you
lose your wallet one day your phone will
tell you right where it is and if you
use apple's tracking service their new
wallets actually come air tag ready
extra wallets are made from high quality
environmentally friendly materials and
have a built-in rfid block to prevent
wireless theft it's basically just the
james bond wallet at this point extra
has a bunch of different wallet styles
and options to fit your personal taste
and if your wallet is still looking like
this then please it is time to let go
because extra is offering y'all 25 off
at checkout by clicking the link in the
description 25 off to level up that
wallet game
[Music]
yes
yes indeed y'all click that link in the
description it helps me out helps boost
the channel up
and if you all are trying to get some
slim
smart wallets that's the way to go so
thanks for listening thanks for taking
the time y'all
um
where do we begin today
um let's look at some art first and
foremost
so
this is where i'm at
right let's um let's full screen this
thing
okay i spent the entire week
working on this dang character and he
looks real janky now i'll tell you tell
you this much it looks really really
janky a little bit it's the eyeballs you
know it's the dead eyes but you're not
gonna see those because we got some vr
goggles over this thing um
yeah they're going to be doing some
stuff i've been struggling to get this
character
looking proper
with the mocap data
and then simulating these darn pants too
has just been a struggle for me i don't
do this every day
i do it maybe once every 3d challenge
and it's always such a struggle for me
and it just makes me want to
not do character-based challenges
anymore but hey you know that's the
point of these challenges is to learn
um so i'm glad i'm learning a little bit
here i want to get a darn character
workflow figured out
um
so that was that has been my week is
working on
the character and trying to get them to
move properly so i'm still figuring that
out um i'm learning a new program daz
which is it's just cool you know but i
feel it's a little
i don't know i'm learning i'm learning
what else did i do since last week i
added these cables um in c4d and put
these little cable protectors down
and i raised the stage up and actually
gave it some depth here
i think it's a bit more accurate what
else did i do um oh this ladder right
here crucial this ladder oh my goodness
i can't tell you how crucial
this ladder is y'all um
so i added that
what else um oh i did i improved the
little like saggy
ceiling
thing that we did at the end of the last
stream i simulated this in c4d it was
just a cloth sim and kind of sagged it
down and pinned these little top parts
here
the normals are wrong so you can't
really see it but yeah it's kind of like
a little tabletop situation an inverted
tabletop
so that looks um
you know just a little bit of more more
detail there
um
i think i added like a little small
stuff like this but today what we're
going to be doing right um
on the stream
is adding windows to these walls back
here
so that we can look out to a cityscape
in the background
and the reason that we're going to do
this i've been trying to figure out how
to include an outdoor element to this
and i didn't really know the answer
until i was showing this to the musician
who i think this is the first time
i've ever talked about the music so
my very very very good friend
um
may even be my my very best friend uh
adam
he goes by feverkin
y'all can find him on spotify
and
he
is doing the music for the moving
meditations 3d challenge he also did the
music for alternate realities so he's
putting together a number of songs for
this challenge for the top 100 montage
it's going to be incredible i've been
listening to the demos and working with
him on you know getting the right sound
and finding the right direction and he's
great you know i can just trust him to
most of what i of what i get from him is
just like dude this sounds great i can't
wait to see the 100 version even though
you're you're at 20 now and it's
sounding awesome so the 100 is gonna be
great but the reason i bring him up is i
showed him my render and he said
whoa that's super cool the
i love the those hills in that sky like
that early morning sky i'm like what are
you talking about dude
and he's like yeah man like the city in
the background
and like
the way your horizon line is set is
super cool i'm like dude are we looking
at the same render
what
and he was like oh my god
and i can kind of see what he's saying
now like if you squint
and make the youtube video like super
small you can actually kind of see what
he's talking about so
right on the horizon line we have these
servers right that we that we put in i
think on the last stream
and if you imagine these servers as like
hills
that are just totally blacked out
because it's super low light in the
background imagine this is an underpass
and
these walls back here are the super
early morning light that you see
and i was like dude that is insane
um because i've been trying to figure
out the outdoor element to this
and i figured instead of making this an
underpass because i'd have to
redo a lot of the interior
um to make it a road and all this and
that i'm like no i'm not doing that but
what i think i can do
is just add some windows
to the walls here
and
put some buildings like a cityscape in
the background
with a super early morning light set up
and i think that could
give it a very unique kind of flavor so
that's what i'm going to do here on the
stream that's exactly what i'm going to
do so i'm going to be in c4d adding
windows
modeling some very very basic building
block kind of kind of stuff here
and i'm going to be using kit bash
assets uh in unreal five here
into the background and we're gonna have
to figure out a way to make a uh
a night
scene
with these buildings because kit bash
doesn't come with
um like a like a night map or a light
map for
the skyscrapers they have like neon
signs and whatnot but they don't have
you know like
people in individual rooms with their
lights on so we're gonna have to create
one on stream hopefully we'll have
enough time to get there we'll see we'll
see but we got a lot to do today
um
speaking of kit bash we do have
kit bash codes to give out there's 50
only there's only 50 so grab them while
you can
and look let me just double check the
code here
i don't want to get it wrong
that would not be good
so we got 50 kit bash codes if you go to
kitbash3d.com
the link is in the description if you
use the code
meditation 30 you get 30 off your entire
order
go check them out kit bash is super cool
um they make
i mean if you all don't know what kit
bash is at this point they make a ton of
super awesome themed
uh kits
uh with hundreds of assets
per kit
and they're all themed to different
styles sci-fi
uh western
uh brutalist architecture they got a
whole bunch of stuff
um and they're pretty crucial for
creating
any sort of environment that you guys
are trying to create so go check them
out
use the discount code if you all are
trying to uh
trying to get a little discount on that
we got it pinned up at the top of the
chat here
okay
let's hop in we got a lot of work to do
f11 we'll switch you out
from full screen um control shift s will
save all
the first thing i want to do is
add these windows and i think before we
can add these windows what i need to do
is
make sure that we're gonna have enough
room to see whatever we're trying to see
so let's grab all of these switchboards
and put them in a folder so we can
have our stuff organized top right you
see this little folder button let me
just call these switch boards
amazing we'll drop that into geometry
i'm kind of organizing this stuff as i'm
going because there is a ton of stuff
here
in our scene
uh we can even group those two
that's gonna be ctrl g
so you select one and they're all
selected okay
and i want to turn these off i just want
to hide these for a second
um
you can even hide this little generator
and think if we had
if we got rid of these walls
they're already grouped let's ungroup
them ctrl shift g i believe will ungroup
yep i'm gonna grab all these guys
and just bring them down a little bit
okay
all right
i just want to rough in what i think it
could look like if we did this
i got some detail here um that i'm going
to get rid of just for a second also i
have this like
camera distortion if you look on the
right side of frame you can see how that
pillar doesn't bend
it's not linear it's not straight up and
down it actually bends and that's a
post-processed material we talked about
this in the first
moving meditation stream
i'm gonna turn that off so i can select
my stuff properly
hide this
okay
um
this starts to give us kind of an idea
of what an exterior vibe would look like
now
we have a very basic lighting setup i
think this is a default lighting setup
for exterior yeah we have directional
light
exponential height fog sky atmosphere
skylight all this good stuff okay but
here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna save
and i'm going to delete
all of it
clint you're crazy why would you do such
a thing well
it's because i'm going to use a plugin
called ultra
dynamic sky i think that's the name of
it
i just started using it recently and
really love it so if y'all
buy stuff on
the marketplace right this is the epic
games launcher you have the marketplace
tab where you can buy different elements
but usually it's just like
they're free for the month stuff most of
this is just stuff i got for free
because
epic is just awesome and they give you
all that stuff it looks like we have an
update for ultra dynamics guys so i'm
going to update that real quick
and show you how easy it is to bring
this stuff into your project so
i want to add this to my project it's
going to add it to my open project
i just totally lied i get to choose um
let's add it to the project
and it's going to take two seconds and
it's done and it's added so on the left
here
let's
find our ultra dynamic sky and if we go
to blueprints and pull out the ultra
dynamic sky
blueprint and drop it into our scene
we're gonna get
what looks to be like a normal-ish
looking daylight setup similar to what
we just deleted okay
also i just realized we got some super
chats to say thank you to maximus
appreciate you
um never in my life will i be able to
explain what you've done for me thank
you for leading me to my passion huge
fan keep up the incredible work glad to
be here dude that is amazing to hear
um
heck yeah dude i'm super happy for you
that's amazing thank you for the for the
support
it's very very helpful and i'm glad that
i
could have a tiny part in
doing what i do here
on the channel
um
and i'm glad that you you know
you took that and uh
and made it your own
and found your path i think that's great
also a.m
i see you all the way at the top of the
chat
aya hiya there
thank you for the support y'all are
awesome thanks for hanging out with me
um okay so
let us see
what the sky looks like bam all right so
it looks pretty normal right um
you can see our clouds are moving very
subtle let's take a look at ultra
dynamic sky actor and
mess with some settings
so the time of day of course we can
move this all around
right that looks freaking awesome
super cool
we can drop this
the sky or sorry we can drop the sun
underneath
and look at that this is kind of the
lighting i'm going for you can even see
the stars if youtube compression allows
you can see the stars and we can take
cloud coverage what do we want what do
we just say zero we just say no clouds
we just want a beautiful
horizon
we can take this down to night time
right
lots of cool stuff we can do here we can
take our cloud coverage back up to two
so it's really thick
very overcast
we can take the fog up if we want
come on now
super foggy
if we take the cloud coverage back to
the default
1.14
keep taking that fog up
i'm down into here but i'm feeling like
no clouds like we originally set up
so we'll do zero on the cloud coverage
we can do zero on the fog and let's just
take that sun
just below the horizon like it's just
gonna be coming up
basically i'm going for
sicario
lighting
um
let me see if i can give you an example
of sicario lighting and what i mean by
sicario lighting
um
let's see let's see i had it in a chat
with uh with adam here
here we go ah the best
beautiful absolutely beautiful
this is sicario lighting
boom if you've never seen the movie
sicario
i mean do yourself a favor
it's one of the best movies
goodness gracious
denis villeneuve
villanu
i can never pronounce his last name
um
but yeah it's the same dude who directed
blade runner 2049
he directed dune
as of late
and this is roger deakins one of the
greatest cinematographers of all time
and just this shot alone like you have
these soldiers they're going into uh
to infiltrate some caves
and they're all moving from right to
left and they descend into the horizon
just going into a swampy black
darkness
yeah so good but these are the colors
i'm going for at least at first right so
um
let's just drop the sun
come on just a little just a little
too much too much 1700
okay
okay
1800 perhaps
that's perfect all right so we can take
that
kind of what we're going for let's bring
up our sequencer that's um
kind of where i have my camera moves in
and whatnot so
under content let's open up our
sequences folder this is all just
stuff that i'd set up over the weeks
during these live streams
so open this up i'm actually going to
pop this out
bring it onto my other monitor
um but i'll quickly quickly give you a
rundown of what's going on here before i
do that um
so basically you can drop cameras in
here from your outliner if you search
for your cine cameras
and i'm putting them into my scene of
course by
searching cine camera in the place
actors window there's a lot of ways to
add cameras but this is one of them you
can pop it in here g is going to show
and hide
your objects in the scene you can right
click it to pilot the camera
um but
i'm just dragging it from here into the
sequencer
and you can click this little these
little buttons here on the right and
that's going to take you into the camera
and what i've done here is actually
given them keyframes to ensure that if
i'm in this camera and i'm like oh but
you know i want to navigate my scene and
keep building and i realize oh shoot i'm
in the camera
i changed the camera angle i had it
locked it was great because i have these
keyframes here on all these transform
values um i just you know quick it'll
quickly reset itself if i try and hit
play so that's one one way i'm like kind
of ensuring that i don't mess up my
camera stuff this one is locked for the
challenge
uh it has the the dolly zoom effect here
um so that's all locked in and then i
have this other one here this is going
to be my custom camera move that i set
up for the intro of the top 100 and all
renders montage and if i hit play it's a
very very very subtle
slow dolly
right
this is all real time
super slow dolly that moves in
it's also zooming in
a little jerry
there we go
right and it's going to zoom into this
character who's going to
have all this vr stuff on them and wires
and stuff um so i'm pretty much trying
to wrap out the final environment today
and then spending the rest of the week
on the character alone
if you're if you're real sharp you
notice i got some camera shake here too
that's just your classic william foshee
camera shake tutorial go check him out
he's one of the best of all time when it
comes to unreal engine tutorials
um so that's how the sequencer works i
will just have that off to the side
um
the reason i bring it up is because i
want to see
what my camera angle is
okay
so the sky um
let's make some adjustments here
we can take the saturation in our
ultradynamic sky
object and take it to two and it's gonna
crank that saturation
we can probably raise the sun a little
bit
more because it's behind
right um
17.75
1800
1850
somewhere between 18 25.
super subtle very very very very very
subtle
um
but we'll still have our walls right
we'll still gonna have our walls we're
gonna add windows i'll probably add a
little vignette
um
and then i'll probably bring in
maybe i can bring those servers back in
what the heck what what do we call them
shoot
switchboard
switchboards
yes
flea flea guy
flea guy number one
um
you probably mean fly fly guy number one
hey thanks for all the work on these
challenges this is my first and i've
spent the month uh making my best work
yes that is the best news for me to hear
uh i would not have had the motivation
to do it without this and made lots of
friends yay yay dude that's even better
news you you're you're learning you're
growing you're pushing yourself you're
meeting new people
um
and it's your first challenge so
congratulations for taking that dive
thank you for the super chat very kind
of you
and uh good luck on this last week here
definitely take your time to make sure
you have at least
you know just don't rush the submission
make sure you have time to like make
some changes
um fix some little tweaks here and there
and you'll be totally fine you'll be
good to go
hey flag i recognize you from the voice
chats how are you doing
yeah
always good to be hopping in the voice
chat on the discord server throughout
the week we got people working
around the clock to make some cool art
um so that's awesome
all right
i
might
okay i might raise
the ceiling here
a little higher so we have a bit more
room so what i want to do is
isolate just the ceiling
so that we can move it up and down i'm
going to leave the lights where they are
because i think they're in a good spot
but in terms of just being able to see a
little bit more
of the horizon i might
i might bring the roof
up a touch
but
i think i'm going to hop into c4d first
and build out these windows so
what i'm gonna do here
is
find reference
for these windows
and let me actually see i may have
pulled some already i'll show you what i
got
because reference is key
it's the quickest way to work
oh i didn't save it i didn't save it
all right so i'm just gonna do some
googling on the side here
where house windows let's bring up the
reference board
this is america all right this music
video they have windows in here kind of
what i'm going for
strip of windows across the entire wall
it looks like they're broken up by these
little uh
pillars here there's like a main
thick
frame and then there's thinner frames
that's all i really need to do to be
honest with you i don't need to get
tricky with it i just need
to do some basic building block kind of
stuff okay
um
this is another good reference this is
inception
look at their windows they're they're
very very large ceiling to floor windows
that is what i'm going for i want to see
as much of the outside as possible so
this is another great reference
they are it seems to be giant clusters
of windows
um
and they are separated by
um by pillars so i think the way to do
this is to
do the pillars
in
after start after effects what am i
saying do the pillars in unreal
but just make a tileable window
frame essentially in c4d
i
think
i think that is the best way to do it
makes the most sense to me
it'll be the fastest as well
so
let's um let's work towards that i think
this is
good enough reference
and matter form my goodness thank you
for the super
chat
what type of smell do you think your set
would have if you could smell it i'll
tell you right now it would be that
abandoned smell uh when you go urban
exploring and you walk into a building
that's a little musty
um it would smell a little um
dusty and metallic and old
a little bit
that's a very interesting very very
interesting question
it would probably smell like
uh
the corridor office
it might smell
what are you saying clinton you saying
the corridor office is dusty and old
i am saying that actually it is it is
right next to the freeway it rains
diesel dust on that place
um
and it was an old paint factory actually
it's an old they're old warehouse spaces
so it is literally in the warehouse
district
so it would probably smell a little bit
like uh
old warehouse and maybe a little bit
of diesel dust
um
all righty
all right
let us begin let us start by opening
cinema 4d
awesome new little
r26 background i just updated it
recently
all right
shaboom
all right we in c4d
um
it's my program of choice has been so
since cinema 4d r10 that would be
[Music]
16
what
really no
i think they're starting to put out a
version every six months at this point
it seems
um but i started in an r10 we're on r26
at this point
okay
so
there are many ways
many
many ways to build out these windows and
technically i can do this
in
uh
an unreal engine
but i'm doing it in c4d okay
i don't think like i said we do not need
to get tricky with it
i'm keeping this darn
simple
folks darn simple okay
i'm holding alt and left click to orbit
and i did something that jacked up my
scene so ctrl n to make a new one yep
okay back to normal um
what is this
right click
i got i'm using a pen tablet alt right
click to zoom in and out and then alt
middle click to orbit
to move rather sorry
all right
framework
framework
let's start with a
[Music]
a tube
and a person so we know how big person
is always do a little person for scale
here i'm gonna give this tube
four sides
i'm gonna rotate this tube
what hit i'm gonna rotate this tube 45
degrees
and i'm just making a quick little frame
here
that will be
the basis for our uh our windows
knowing this let's see let's uh
take the tube
make sure the height and width are the
same i want it to be square
yikes that's not what i wanted height
we'll just go 10
this will go to 90 and that will make it
square amazing amazing amazing okay
um see to make it editable my
axis is jacked up because we rotated it
at 45 and hit l for the axis tool and
just
go back another 45 holding shift to snap
hit l again and we're good to go t for
scale
and i'm just going to click and drag
actually i'm not going to do that what
i'm going to do
there's probably so many better ways to
do this already i'm just
doing it the stupid way zero
right is going to be our move tool let's
move this out
let's move this one out
same here
and same here
all right so it's a pretty big surface
area
can take the tube
r for rotate holding shift 90
right okay that's so it's a window
for sure
pretty big pretty large i think we can
duplicate this
it's about two times okay
i think this could work we could always
scale it up and down in unreal engine as
well
all right so this will be our our frame
here
and i think this works for what we're
going for i can maybe
skinny these up
a little bit more
remove those up a touch
and move them out a touch
yep yep
awesome we also don't need these lines
so ul for loop selection and
m n
to remove them
i think it's dissolve if you right click
oh m n where is dissolve dissolve
dissolve
dissolve yes m n is the hotkey learn
your dang hotkeys
it'll save you tons of time
all right um
what is
next
let's see
i'm going to make a cube
i'm going to scale it down
and b for wireframe
n
b
i can get rid of the figure because we
know how
big it is now we know where our scale is
going to be
all right and i'm going to just zero
this out
this tube
ah
let's see
come on now
all right that way we can just spawn
everything from the middle here
okay and with the cube let's take
this down to like three
all right
and
let's set up
an array
or a cloner rather all right so i'm
gonna hold alt with the cube selected
and if we just click this little button
here on the right
boom we're gonna make a cloner and it's
gonna clone it a bunch of times in a
certain specific way all right but the
way we want to do it
uh linear is probably what we want we
don't want to
clone it in the y direction we don't
want to go up we want to go left and
right
okay
and you know what now that i think about
it grid is probably the answer because
we can go from the center out
all right so we will
do one one and let's try like
10.
all right but it's going past our frame
i think we can set this to end point and
have the end point be
the end of our frame here
that way
i think if we add more yep it'll do
do it appropriately here now what i will
do is also
duplicate the cloner control c control v
and let's turn it off for a second let's
turn the other cloner off let's just
turn all that stuff off except for this
other cube in this duplicate cloner i'm
going to go 90 on it
stretch it to the bounds of our frame
here
bring the cloner back in
ah but it's
messing it up because we already preset
our clone
again different ways to go about solving
problems here in 3d but i'm going to
just redo it alt hit the clone button
take that down
we set it to end point we bring our
endpoint to the
proper
right just so it's hidden
right underneath that frame
and then we can
duplicate
turn our other one on
and we start to have
a nice little uh little window pane set
up here now these windows aren't square
they're actually rectangle
so what i will do
is just give us less
on the top here we go 6
or more of a rectangular again based off
of this reference here
rectangular windows and we also see that
there are some like
frames inside of the frames and there's
some dividing frames too so let's start
with the dividing frames and then we'll
go
with the frames inside the frames now
those frames inside the frames those are
windows that you can rotate and open i
know because i sat right next to one on
hunter street
and it's that thing swiveled if you hit
your head on it you were done
so let's um
let's work in our well first off let me
get rid of this dang
world grid
it's the world god no it's not the world
act it's the work plane get rid of this
work plane i'll take the
the world axis i'll give you that
save save save save save
this is called
window
frame
oh and this is the wrong folder vfx
e4b window frame bam all right
y'all i have a video that i filmed like
two years ago on
file organization
and how to organize your computer and
the folders and all your assets in a way
that is the best way i was searching for
the best way and i interviewed
every artist i could think of
well no that's why i interviewed um
notable artists on youtube and i asked
them for one tip that they had for their
organizational methods and their
workflow
um
and it's a beast of an edit because
there's a lot of footage to go through
but
maybe
i will unearth that video at some point
um
because i think it's a good one i think
it's a very very good one to know it's
how to organize your stuff that way you
can work efficiently and fast
okay
so let us divide this into two
pieces maybe
or maybe we figure out like
what our
okay let's let's try a thing let's try a
thing
we want to figure out where the windows
and the dividing lines are all right so
let's make a
spline here
a rectangle spline
okay
and i'm gonna scale it
down here
[Music]
and bring the height down
boom right so it's in there all right so
the rectangle spline is in there i'm
going to make another rectangle spline
let's hide all this stuff just so you
can see what i'm doing
so that's kind of our window frame right
with the spline
from here i'll make another rectangle
just be a square i'll hit t for scale
i'll scale it way down it doesn't need
to be
that's our thickness that's gonna be our
thickness
i'll select both of them
hit ctrl alt that's going to ensure that
the
[Music]
sweep we put these in
just automatically become
children of this parent sweep all right
and from here this is probably the best
way to do this
um we're going to take the sweep
and actually we control the thickness
with
this other rectangle right
and if we bring our stuff back
we can see okay
there's a little window there i like
that it's a nice little uh nice little
window
so
i think what we can do
if i want to make this a four-tiered
window
or even a five-tiered window let's see
i'm gonna need more
more bits here on the
x
and we'll open that up
a little wider
something like that
and just for
visual clarity here
let's make that harder to see
um let's
do a little thing here uh
let's get another one
boom and boom all right
sweet
i feel like this needs to be larger
though so here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna take that sweep that we did for
the window and make this actually the
frame because this is just a better way
to do it
i'm gonna open this up
larger
i'll keep the height
let's see why is that
there we go
all right and then we'll take our
cloners and just extend the end point
to match our updates
i just want to give a little bit more
room here
let's get rid of this old frame
and extend these guys
a little bit further
awesome
and then we'll adjust our main central
frame
this is uh
border
window one
vertical and horizontal
sweet
okay
so these windows are broken up into like
tall rectangles it looks like
so
it's probably broken up into three
pieces here let's grab
a
cube
we'll scale it down
stretch it out
drop our material on it
and see if we can't divide this
into three even chunks and it looks like
we got it
all right that's great
take this window
bring it in just a bit
mhm
this is five okay yeah nice nice
maybe let's go one higher um
oh do we not we don't want to do that i
feel like we don't want to i feel like
this is pretty good this is pretty darn
good
we're getting nitpicky at this point and
that doesn't need to be a thing so
we can take this
and ctrl drag it over
ctrl drag it over
this is kind of our window setup um
if we want to open the window
dang it let's get that
center point back
weird
weird
ah it's because this guy
needs to be
yeah there we go the windows will open
like this
the outside now we have to technically
delete if we're going to be opening
windows these frames need to come with
these guys
so that's not a big deal it's just going
to take a little bit of time and i need
to ask myself
am i going to have open windows i think
it would be nice i think it would help
break up
the vibe a little bit
so what's the best way to set that up
steve begin in the house unreal sensei
the man
who single-handedly
taught me
unreal engine um
every every friday was a few hours
of unreal education
so to mr steve begin sensei steve
shout outs and i appreciate you very
much
we're creating some windows here
and we're going to bring them into
unreal engine
and give our scene
a little exterior element because it's
mostly interior you know i want to bring
a little bit of that exterior in
to the interior
windows are a great way to do that who
knew
all right
so if we want these frames to come with
these things
um i would say the best way to do this
would be
to make one
of these i'm not gonna do it three times
so knowing what we know now
all in hindsight am i right in hind
sight we're gonna we're going to
take our border
and let's bring
the width in
boom
there
i just want to make one of these
and it is five by five
looking like
cool all right um from here
let's delete
these guys
all right this is our one piece that
we're going to duplicate a bunch of
times
and we can open up the windows if we
want
so
what's the best way
to do this is probably
bake this down
i'm gonna first duplicate it ctrl drag
and then ctrl g
i like alt g i'm gonna just call this
back this is our backup in case things
fail i'm gonna alt hold alt and double
click these little stopwatches here to
turn it off
so we don't see it
um
i'm going to hit c and bake
this cloner
and
i'm going to figure out
let's see well first
first
why is that like that interesting let's
bring this up just a bit
there we go
cool all right um this is gonna rotate
bam
right there just like that
so let's uh
and nb
to bring up our wireframe
we'll basically make some cuts
along this thing or what we can
many ways to do this many ways
make these editable
kl
your knife cut tool kl
and we're essentially going to make some
cuts along here
and delete some geometry
so we'll delete
we want to delete
let's see this and we don't want those
actually those are fine it's these guys
it's this one here
boom boom
and we're going to detach it so let's go
to
polygon mode
and ul for loop selection we're going to
grab that we're going to hit up we're
going to disconnect it u p disconnect
we'll go back to the original and delete
that geometry so now what we have
is
we have this broken up into two parts
right so when we move this window around
and technically we probably only need to
do this with the vertical ones
because the middle one will stay
in fact so i'm going to undo that the
middle one is going to stay
it's the verticals that need to be cut
and attached all right so let's find
these verticals
so i'll make verticals editable
we'll make these cubes editable by
hitting c
let's go to line mode kl
boom
boom
boom
amazing amazing amazing
these guys will go one we'll go two all
right sweet
loop selection ul
boom up for disconnect
and we'll go back to the original geo
and delete it
boom so now we have it separate it looks
the same but now we can actually put
this
into
where are you
is it window
if we group window
and put
that little slat in there
yay
that's exactly what we want let's do it
on the other side
boom uh
kl loop cut we already made the cuts up
loop selection in
sorry ul is the loop selection and then
up is disconnect go back to the original
geo delete it
and drop
that guy up in that null and now
we should have a working window that
opens
but we do need to delete
these borders here these guys need to be
deleted as well we'll get that in a
second player four what is up we got
super chat popping off hey clint do you
have any tips for foreground lighting a
night
sunset scene everything i do just feels
off
thanks as always for the positive vibes
um
thank you for the super chat any tips on
foreground lighting
a night
or sunset scene
william foshea has a great tutorial on
how to light a night scene
i would definitely check that out it's
an unreal engine one but it can be
applied to any
i mean he what what william does so well
is he goes and he looks at
cinematography he looks at how
people are lighting movies
um to achieve these effects and and it's
all based off of movies literally all
the stuff that we're coming up with and
trying to reference it starts with
photography and it starts with movies
and movies have gotten so good to the
point where
they're just the the best references
um and of course there's a lot of
amazing 3d references but when it comes
to lighting people have spent their
entire lives
studying film and getting good at
lighting film so study that take a look
at i use shot deck is a great website
to look up different uh
screen grabs from a bunch of different
movies you look up the movie and it'll
pull up a bunch of screenshots and you
can take a look so if you're watching a
movie and you notice oh that night scene
looks really nice
um well
take note you know take a little
screenshot or something um
you know maybe look it up on shot deck
so you're gonna try and build a
reference pool of
uh
really nice well-lit night
scenes all right or sunset scenes
so that's what i would do is i would
just go to shot deck and i would look up
sunset
or i would go to shot deck and i would
look up
night foreground foreground sunset and
see what you see and see if you can find
that shot that really is kind of what
you're going for or a few elements of
what you're going for and
put that into a program called pureref
it's what i use
to is you know this program here y'all
you know i'm kind of on repeat at this
point
but i feel like it's always good to kind
of take it back to the basics and talk
about because there's there's someone
new in this chat you know there's
someone new on the stream who hasn't
been here before and
this is great info for them and it's
also good
to review stuff too but yeah i use pref
and i drop all my reference in there so
that would be my
my my uh my advice to you
without seeing your scene specifically
if you want to you know pop an object
out you want to edge light something you
want to backlight something so you have
a nice little silhouette
drawing you have a nice bright high
contrast line of light
kind of on their back right side back
left side
um to pop them out from the background
um you can use
it really depends on your scene i think
that's the best advice i can give
without seeing your scene so good luck
to you thank you for the super chat
player four good stuff
all right
back to this window
okay
um
anyone in chat here if you guys are
working on your moving
meditations 3d challenge
submission give me a little thumbs up
give me that thumbs up if you're working
alongside with me and hey even if you're
working in 3d on something that isn't
this challenge but you're just working
in 3d
give me a thumbs up
oh and i'm curious
wizales
red reticulus
today i'm that new guy in chat yes
what's up wizales
thank you for repeating things also un
unearth
the organa
i don't know what that means
um
but i i feel you
i
i feel you
thanks for the super chat though thanks
for saying hello welcome to the stream
uh shout outs to you
um
if this is your first
live stream the first one you tuned into
give me a little smiley face in the chat
here
we got a lot of people working on 3d art
we see them thumbs i see them thumbs
beautiful beautiful thumbs
if you're new to the streams if this is
your first one give me a little smiley
face
curious
my organization video ah
my organization unearthed
the organization video yes agreed man
agreed
yeah
shout outs everybody good to see y'all
in chat here thank you
for sticking around with me
we got just we got like 500 people
500 people in chat popping off is a good
time
yeah william for shay's the best
oh that's awesome y'all thank you
we got people we got passionate 3d
artists in the chat right now
let's amp things up
and finish this window
3d is difficult it's not always uh
you know it's not always a
super entertaining joy to watch others
do 3d but i hope i'm doing my best here
all right
verticals let's get these verticals
sliced
first let's undo
the windy yeah well let's figure out
what we want we want to bring these guys
on the side with us we also want to
bring these guys on them
now the ones on the bottom will stay
but these ones on the side they're going
for a ride here okay
let's grab that
uh
ul in polygon mode for
a loop selection bam it's happening
behind scenes up
to disconnect grab the original geometry
delete it
drop it in to the window
folder and now when we move the window
oh my god
is that how it works hold on let me
think about this i actually don't think
that's how it works
i think we
i think we had it right the first time
i gotta i gotta really think back to my
hunter street days
yep that's how it works this is how it
works just like this
all right the last thing i'll do is
let's get a
let's get a plane in here because this
will be our glass we're going to get
some smudges it's gonna get dirty all
right
um
so let's grab
that polygon
is all we need we're gonna rotate it 90.
and let's go ahead and
get t for scale
scale this mug up
bam
c to make it editable
object mode we're gonna scale it up here
bam that's our window but we want to
make some slices
in edge mode
kl loop cut bam there's one
bam there's two
three and four we're gonna cut out our
window
cutting out that window
back to polygon mode nine is your
selection tool
peekaboo
we didn't need to do that i lied u p u p
disconnect
we'll drop that into the null and now
now
now
we have a window
we can peek out of
amazing
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it
oh
how long did that take guys
how long did it take
the details that count am i right
oh
ah
ah
peaking i'm peaking now i'm sorry
everybody i'm sorry
okay
let's name our crap okay uh
this is window
pain
is that how you spell window pane
not the other way around
um we have our
i want to combine as much of this as
possible because
um
unreal is gonna try and separate
everything or keep it all together
wolfie what's going on we're making
windows we're going to bring them into
our unreal engine environment we're
going to make some windows we're going
to get a nice background going we're
going to get a cityscape going it's
going to be sick nasty all right
um
all right
we actually do
need to separate that middle one because
it comes with the window
you think about the save polar bears
what's up good to see you
shout outs to you
i'll get you here in just a second let
me undo this bam all right so nearing
the end of the monthly challenge makes
you think back to when i couldn't find
out how to rotate an object for my first
ever scene
dude that is some progress
tell me about it man
wow
cherish that that's a good feeling man
very very very good feeling
i'm gonna read that again because it's
important nearing the end of the monthly
challenge makes me think back to when i
couldn't find out how to rotate an
object
for my first ever scene
dude hats off to you that's some
progress
congratulations seriously
take that one to the grave keep thinking
about that too that's that's important
we want to think about where we came
from we're hard on ourselves
we're always struggling it's just like
dark souls it's always hard
because we keep leveling up
it's just like writing goodness gracious
writing is very hard and it will all
forever always forever be hard if you
are continually growing and learning
but when you think back to how it was at
the beginning when you first started
wow that gap is massive
so that is awesome so
keep it up y'all keep it up village boy
what's up son
love from india i hope to make it down
there one day
yeah sunken mud working alongside with
my first project that's what's up
utsav what is up hello hello
dark souls yeah
love me some dark souls
all right let's focus
so i know that i want to break this up
into different
pieces in unreal engine i want to be
able to texture this with a window
right this is our window here
we also have a window there so maybe
what we do is we we actually bring it
into unreal engine as
individual
objects
because we want to texture it
from there
so let's think about what we can combine
and what
we aren't going to combine
so
[Music]
all right
[Music]
our window
this is our glass
and we can combine these if we right
click and connect objects plus delete
this is our frame
and we can select it and actually hit
solo here
and i believe if we select the hierarchy
yeah
that's our window
with the frame
broken up into
oh okay okay we i think we we can
actually take the window
i'm gonna save this
and
save it actually as a new
a new setup here window frame 2
in case we need to make adjustments
and i'm going to bake this down
so i'm going to take these frames right
click
connect objects plus delete all right
frame
it's looking good all right
that's going to be colored the same
color
frame and our glass
that's our window
and then we have
let's see we have uh let's turn off solo
this is more glass
we have our main
frame
the main frame can go with
these vertical and horizontals i believe
we take this right click
connect objects plus delete
and if we solo it
that's all going to be one color
that makes sense to me
cool and if we move our window still is
working correctly all right amazing
so we got it down to three four objects
we have glass one
main main glass
main frame and then we have glass and
frame
let's do uh
window glass
window
frame
cool
boom
boom all right and we'll handle the rest
in unreal engine i'm going to delete
that
let's
copy
these guys ctrl c
into a new
scene here
all right and i'm going to file
export fbx
okay
and
let's go vfx
assets
models
window
frame
boom
let's bring it
into unreal engine let's find our mesh
our studio
and
bring this guy on in
now when we import this we want to be
sure we have combined meshes unchecked
we want those four individual meshes so
we can texture properly
um
transform our input scale
as one that's totally fine materials
we
we don't need materials so i'm going to
just uh material do not create material
we're going to make our own materials
and we'll import all it's going to bring
in our four bits here i'm going to make
a new folder call this window
frame
come on now f2 to rename
what
i'm confused
window frame all right let's just drop
all of that into there move
sweet and we can bring all this out
together
so now if i right click and use wasd to
move around we have a window frame space
bar will toggle between
rotation scale and position
right
and all of these actually let me undo it
because it's probably easier just to
have all this stuff selected at once
boom i'm gonna put this in its own
folder
yikes
here we go boom they're all selected i'm
gonna hit the folder
call this window
frame
wait what
[Music]
geez i'm confused what just happened
new folder
[Music]
bam i'm gonna put that uh let's group
these ctrl g to group
why is that not working
right click
[Music]
weird
i wonder why that's not working oh also
oh
i see from this side okay
we have our window
all right i'm going to take a very short
break and when we come back i'm going to
give it some glass
and start moving them around and see
open up some of these windows and see
what it looks like so i'll be back in uh
i don't know
a couple minutes
so hang out for just touch and i'll see
you guys in two seconds
sotomonte if he gets his mic situated
it might keep y'all company
two seconds
[Music]
hello
oh yeah that's how we walk let me fix
that real quick
[Music]
all right there i am um
yeah let me read some chat i guess
hello fly guy hello again
hey one aspiring artist that's a pretty
cool name
i should join this right after dude
after this i'm going to dinner man
i met up with some friends to grab lunch
before
uh preparing the stream and everything
but this is like a whole afternoon
operation so maybe after dinner we'll
see we'll see
but yeah
what's my day job um
answering to our board uh i'm a student
still i'm gonna start
so i dropped out of university to change
degrees and
yeah i'm gonna start my first year again
pretty soon in like 10
12 days
i look young um yeah i'm kind of yeah
where am i gonna eat in the kitchen
how did the pan photoshop turn out all
right that's pretty nice um but yeah we
were talking on this curve
um and i was photo scanning scanning a
pan i ended up changing my method um
like i used flour but without sugar with
water
so just flour
3am for one aspiring artist um
you know i don't know how good your
sleeping schedule is mine is kind of a
mess right now but you can go to sleep
and then watch the stream once it's like
re-uploaded if you want to
you can get good sleep at least once
when the stream is over at least
[Music]
dyer says good luck at uni thank you
thank you so much
[Music]
this song is so soothing with the like
i can't remember the name of those
metal balls you see in the background
i'm not even gonna try i don't know but
it sounds really good with the
background music i like it
jack tim is asking how long have i been
doing 3d i've been doing it around three
years or so but two years or two and two
and a half years more seriously
[Music]
what is it with japanese says matilda
it's pretty cool
um i know clint is a big big fan of
japanese he he knows a little bit of
japanese and i love that
i remember when he moved houses to the
new one
i think at least in his streaming room
you can see it in the background
actually if you pay attention later but
he has those japanese sliding doors i
think that's super
[Music]
so yeah i guess it's just relaxing
the japanese japanese stuff is really
cool um i'm not a big anime watcher but
i do enjoy the give the studio giveaway
movies a lot they're super fun
all right another question how is it
being a mod for clint pretty fun um
yeah of course i mean every mod
does it because we love it
for sure
but i think it's such a cool thing you
know to
help maintain the community you meet new
people
not every day but you know you you meet
new people and you see them
learn 3d hopefully it's really fun
i like it
do i like donuts um
sure but the homemade ones the other
ones i feel like they're too sweet and
too like
soft almost like
they don't have any substances just like
sugar
who rendered the background says
jerry cho slashy
i don't know um
i think this was for a corridor
challenge where they were trying to do
one of those
satisfying loops on this 16th century i
think
[Music]
you guys know what would be fun if we
think of like a prank we can play on
clint like what if i don't know from now
on every every
chat we finish with that with the same
emoji and we don't explain why you know
like
hello and then we put the calendar or
something i don't know
or like let's let's do
[Music]
this emoji
i'm not gonna tell him why we're doing
it
[Music]
a matrix no i'd rather keep the chat the
same because if we do it to
like if it's something that he's like
what are you guys talking about then he
has to bring it up but if it's just the
emojis he'll be like
they're all having the same emoji at the
end and then finally he might ask maybe
or whatever
did i ever think of dropping out of
college well
technically yes because i'm dropping out
of college to go to a different college
but i think having a university degree
is like a really good thing to have even
if
you have to work
a lot by yourself kind of to get into cg
just by the nature of it you know like
with a degree you're not gonna plan the
job you need to be good i think it's a
really good thing to have either way so
yeah there you go i love seeing the
emoji is coming
[Music]
[Music]
how are you guys doing with the scenes i
guess i guess most of you are or some of
you started working on the
limitations challenge are you guys like
75 there because it's something not no
pressure by the way but 75 of the time
has flown by so
yeah now it's a good time to like render
do a bit of compositing i mean you still
have time to do this stuff
[Music]
so
[Music]
eighty percent
i guess that's that's your eighty
percent done that's pretty good that's
pretty good
nice
[Music]
will clint review working progresses
later um
thick deck probably not on the stream
but every monday so two days from now
um we have a in discord in our district
we have um
[Music]
a stage channel where we bring some some
people up and they show their work in
progress that that might be something
you want to check out maybe
nice nice i see that people are
managing their time well
[Music]
wow
matt walker like started again because
he felt like he could do better wow
really
inspiring i think
yeah
then people struggling with rendering
their huge scene which i guess is a cool
thing in the way that you know it's a
huge scene that's pretty cool
but good luck on optimizing it yeah
[Music]
some people doing everything from
scratch like modeled by themselves
other people use assets um it's really
interesting to see because
when you make everything by by yourself
everything's super cohesive you can see
the theme really well but then if you
use assets then you you can have way
more things because you don't have to
create everything by scratch or from
scratch sorry
so yeah it's an interesting balance for
me i think the best option is to
to use a little bit of assets and then
model the main things by yourself
but of course i'm always happy to do
a challenge so
you know it's fun
anyway i think the
vr army might be
close to over
but yeah
hey another person that did everything
by themselves pretty cool pretty cool
can't wait to see it
so you are correct
you're very correct yes
thanks for uh holding it down thanks for
being patient everyone
no worries
lovely so it was a very long run
to get this kombucha i had to sprint
about a mile
to get it so
they're important you know they're very
important also i think it's a little
bright let me turn this down
i always forget which way there we go
nope that's the wrong way
all right that which way is that here we
go
it'd be very nice to have a monitor at
some point
we'll get there
we'll get there
all right
thanks everybody
[Music]
so many hearts y'all y'all are great wow
shoot fire all right
let it begin
all right let's get a quick little
material
on these guys so
um
glass let's do a basic glass and we'll
go in for surface imperfections if
needed
uh materials
[Music]
master material let's right click make a
new
master material
glass
i have never made glass
i just realized this um translucent
is that literally all i have to do i i
doubt it
material
then translucent
now
uh let's drop this
onto
the window
interesting all right well
could mess around here for a while
or
starter content oh the starter content
all right architecture all right so
here's what here's what you do when you
need
some materials or you need something
that's not in your scene all right so
i'm going to go to
again there's multiple ways to do this
i'm looking for a glass material what's
the other setup all right so
if i navigate to my previous projects
let's see archive
projects
all right and we
pull basically any
unreal engine
project file
that has starter content it has all the
starter content alright so you look for
it basically in your unreal engine
folder tree here we're going to go to
content and if you look for starter
content or whatever i'm constantly doing
this i'm pulling
different um blueprints or
you know different materials or
different
assets that have already been loaded out
and i don't need to do it again i'll
just pull it from something else
so starter content we can just grab
materials right here and drag it in to
our
project directory which is
that's why you know again you want to be
organized always
you know where your stuff is
and you just drag it into the same
folder so under starter content i'm
going to drag my materials
in and we'll have a bunch of materials
you saw it populate there on the bottom
let's go in and just type glass
and here's a glass setup and we can kind
of see how they're building it um
what
i am
confused
i am very confused
does it
need thickness is that why
um it might need thickness
okay
well i'm gonna test that out in
right now i guess
all right so instead of let's do this
glass it's
i think it just needs thickness
so with everything selected ctrl a every
polygon will hit b for uh extrude and we
will create caps
and i'll extrude this
so there's some thickness to this window
and i'll do the same
for
the
the main glass as well
d
for extrude
push it out and we have
some thickness
all right so
let's uh export this again
we'll overwrite our existing window
frame
and in unreal engine
if we click on the object and hit ctrl d
or sorry ctrl b for browse
it'll
navigate you to that object in your
content browser
and if we select all of these and right
click we can
re-import
and it up just updated
and let's try the glass now and see if
that works
wow okay so technically it says it's
applied
uh
oh i'm i'm straight up stumped
all right so you're saying this specific
one doesn't work because
no i mean we dude we should be seeing
this
unless all of these materials i just
brought in
don't work because they're unreal for
materials
is what you're saying
but that doesn't make
oh these are all
oh shoot
well shoot fire i need to figure out how
to make glass then huh
all right let's uh let's first start
with
something we already have
yeah all right so we confirm confirm
that works all right we got
we got that going um but if we go into
our master material
glass
maybe i can double click this
let's see about
all right so it is doing something
change the parameter to translucent
yeah but it's just darkness maybe that's
because i need a color
and it needs to be white
doesn't look right
i'm looking to the chat at this point
y'all
help me sensei steve where you at
uh
shading unless subsurface
clear coat
subsurface two-sided foliage hair off a
single layer water thin translucent
the translucency is controlled by
refraction
okay
[Music]
hmm
let's see slider no paddle opacity uh
opacity is not the answer left click
connect it'll the basement reboot no the
old pack opacity
all right let's try
refraction
so it does need opacity
yeah unfortunately
set the material to forward shading
i don't even see forward shading
all right refraction is doing something
but
i need it to be clear and i need there
to be
uh
[Music]
some some actual
reflections
weird the fact that it's not even
showing up here is crazy
for now i'm going to just hide the
windows
and figure this out
at another point in time
that's weird
that is weird
okay okay i see i see
here we go
all right we wanted to pivot from here
we can right click pivot and set pivot
offset there
that's annoying okay why would it
do that
i said here
do it offset here
yeah okay
all right
let's take these
and i don't know why grouping is not
working that is very strange
and it's not even an option down here
that is that is confusing
very confusing
and it's going to make this difficult
but let's give us a little bit of light
in here so let's go back to the ultra
dynamic sky
get some daylight going
ah i'm in the cinema camera okay let's
get out of that see i did it i did that
mistake
get out
maybe that's why this wasn't a cine
camera can i not group stuff while i'm
in the city makes no sense
also why are these i thought we grouped
these guys too
very strange
sometimes things just don't work you
know
that's unfortunate
all right
so the next thing i want to do i'm going
to duplicate these windows across the
way here but i want to make sure that
here we go
all right so this should probably start
i don't know this wall
should prob where did this wall go
[Music]
all right
so let's bring these up to like knee
height i guess
[Music]
yeah it probably started around like
oh that's a door this this building is
huge
that's like middle of the body almost is
where these things are starting
chest level almost
and
if you select an object and hit f
you'll snap to it
all right
i have the windows just like that
then we can probably take this again
duplicate it raise it up
sweet
nexib
yo that's awesome you you quit because
you couldn't find a solution to an
answer but then you just found the
solution and you're back in it that's
great
[Music]
and yes um
sir bell my first video will be a little
different
from the other renders just because uh
i'm kicking off the challenge
and want to do something that justifies
all the other renders
all right so i'm just kind of on cleanup
duty at this point you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna take a bunch of these
assets and make sure that they're not
coming out of this building i have to
clean things up a little bit more now
all right let's see
let's take this and stretch it out just
a bit
nice okay
just making sure
none of this stuff
pops out of the building
oh it looks like we need a material here
so you can select the object that has a
material you want
and you see down in the bottom right we
can search for it by hitting this little
folder with the search bar and i'll take
you right to it and we can drop this on
nice and easy
awesome
clean up clean up
all right that's a little over extended
how far does it go on this side
um
that one piece that is one piece i bet
you we can delete it
grab all of this holding control
space bar to cycle between position
rotation and scale get it just about
centered
and then we can scale it
oh
no
think that's good
sweet
we're not really seeing anything beyond
i guess this is the last one
awesome
all right so the left side looks to be
good
we can save ourselves
some computer juice and get rid of these
because we're not going to see
heck them that
oh that's a hole okay that's just
blocking light for us that's totally
fine
oh shoot was that the answer was na is
it that nanite does not work
with this stuff
um
okay very interesting
let's turn nanite off
for these
and let's see
yeah you were right you were right
it's doing some weird stuff with
refraction here
very weird
because the reflections aren't
yeah they're not quite there right now
i'm still gonna leave the window turned
off but yo uh who was that
let's see
yeah nexib brand doom thank you
yeah nanite was the answer
heck yeah thank you guys
i'm gonna turn it off for now i'm gonna
dive in deep
at some point and figure that out
also why does it do this
i don't know why like i'll i'll hit save
all
and it'll prompt me to like
save save the new level i don't know why
usually it's just save all and that's it
i'm trying to do file
uh
save all
but then it's prompting me to do this
new level i'm like what the heck
i'm in the same level
so i have to keep making like new
versions of the level
it's asking me again what the heck
i don't understand that
if you have an answer to what i just
tried to describe
at me here in the chat so i can see i've
been trying to figure that one out for a
minute
let's get this back wall going
or is it duplicated is it up here
probably yeah it looks to be
just got to match it up
so
and let's get it looking good on this
side
complete
this
beautiful all right that's all lined up
looking good and then i'll duplicate
this down
sweet all right the disc button works
thank you it is a bug confirmed
um
what the heck is this
rogue
uh sticker it seems or decal and get rid
of that
you know what let's
stand it up and put it on the back here
[Music]
i learned so much from you guys
it's crazy
i'll drag this over to the other side
f will snap us to the object
and yeah that looks that looks good to
me
sweet okay
um
let's uh
bring this roofing back all right so
we have
all right it goes beyond here well let's
get rid of these guys
clean up
lean up
this is actually very satisfying
get our pivot point here in the middle
let's move it over
try and eyeball it here so there's a gap
of equal amounts and then we'll scale it
and if we know we can connect it on one
side then that means it should be
generally connected on the other side
that looks good to me
yup yup yup yup
ah i love optimizing a scene it is
so satisfying
sweet
this one hmm
maybe we can crunch this one down
that that works
oh this one needs uh
this one needs a lot more
amazing
that we don't have to worry about
because we don't even see it
now the question is do these go over the
bounds let's go to our wide angle
they don't so we don't have to worry
about them
all right
i'm gonna go ahead and close
and reopen unreal because i'm getting
some weird bugs
ah
so annoying
hey
what
uh
save current level as
mean three
all right
and it crashed
sweet
all right uh what the heck is all this
[Music]
all right so all the stuff that we had
hidden is back
that's just how it works
our groups look to be working now so
that's good
let's turn off the switchboards
let's group our window ctrl g yes it's
working now
let's get rid of these pipes
let's hide our post process volume
it's not helping with us us with the
selection it's because we're doing a
little lens distortion thing
uh we'll hide the wall pipes
fact
maybe what we'll do
what why is my performance all up now
i'm worried
what did i delete
let's bring these down
the wall pipes
okay
um
get rid of this guy for now
focus on the windows
okay so
what we want to do
is actually give us some borders here
let's separate the windows alright so
let us
ungroup this ctrl shift g will ungroup
let's grab this
duplicate it
and i'm gonna scrunch it down
like so let's take a look at our
reference
see how they're doing it um
yeah okay okay
and i'll mess with the material here in
a second
[Music]
yeah just about like that okay cool
there's a thick
very thick
building there
is the best way to do this let's see
it's at seven let's try it at four
four feels a bit more realistic all
right so i'm gonna go through here and
just
skinny these up
was this one
okay
all right all right
i wish the pivot would stay
where you placed it
that would be handy
cool
julio coolio sweet
you said there's some mega scans
industrial windows that would fit
shoots anything i wasted my time
building out these windows
that would be unfortunate
do i even want to see what they look
like
do i even want to see let's go to qixel
bridge
3d assets
window
yeah
i think we did well
i think we
did
well
yeah
we did a good job i don't have exactly
what i need so that makes me feel a
little bit better
um
all right let's see before we adjust the
material on this let's place them all
right
so i'm going to go to
control spacebar pulls up our content
drawer here
let's go to
our sequences pull that up
i will dock it on the other page
the other window
go to our wide view
and see where these breaks
uh
in the windows would be
ctrl shift g i believe regroups things
yeah
all right so i'm just gonna clear it out
for a second
and see where these would go
probably there and there corners make
the most sense
i can make them skinnier
wait what
now i can't move it what is going on
here
so strange
all right that's what the corner would
look like
i probably want to go a little skinnier
on those
and let's select our cine
camera actor
yeah we can see the view here we'll pin
it
it's going to go real chunky for a
second
basically what three of these windows
we did three of these windows
and then a border
let's see what that looks like on the
sides
because i don't want to cover up too
much of the sky with these borders
because it's all i mean i made these
windows so that we could see outside
right
all right so we just duplicate that
alt drag
and that that takes us out
of the scene there okay
uh we could go one further if we wanted
to just for lighting wise
boom
all right that's not bad
i feel like we can go a little skinnier
though on these separators
because i i really do want to see
a bit more of the outside especially in
the corner here so
let's try
or just like a pillar
something like that
point two whoa
oh two three
0.3 what the heck
yeah that should work point three
and this one should be 0.3 as well
point two three and point two
three
maybe point three point three is good
all right
let's line this up and see what it looks
like
i think this totally works
yeah this
this works
all right great
so from here what i'll do
oh radical isotope says for
architectural and structural structural
realism purposes the external borders
should line up with the interior columns
external borders should line up with the
interior columns
uh
are you saying they should be shifted
forward like this
i think he's saying that the window
separators should be lined up with the
columns
oh those columns
yeah
i see i see
yeah
yeah
in theory i'm sure
i'm cheating it a little bit you know
gotta cheat it a little bit i can try it
but
probably also need one more of these
guys over here
and i'll flip it
something like this
oh cool
um
let's take these windows
boom
and then i'm going to adjust the uh
the tiling here on these columns
nice all right
and i don't need any columns in the back
because you can't see them
let's work on
unpin this get some frame rate back
and work on this material all right so
you can click the object
and in the details panel you can see the
material attached to it we can browse to
it
and i'm going to right click this and
create a material instance of it
and we'll drop it on
here nothing should change
but let's go into it
and adjust the
tiling so i'm gonna check the tiling
offset on
and we'll just go to default see what it
looks like okay so it's stretched out
pretty bad
let's
stand it up i think 2.5 is what it was
at
i think
i think that's what it was at
oh okay so it's jacked up on all
dimensions all right i'll set it to
0.5
and 0.5
0.1
all right not
bad at all except
up in here
i wonder
it's looking good
this side too no okay that's looking
like trash
that's coming from
okay yeah it's all coming from the same
thing
probably not too worried about it just
because
unless
oh no
i think i'm going to leave it for now
because it's probably not that big of a
big of a deal from back there
let's apply it to this one here as well
control b
oh no
that's for the asset itself if we want
the material we gotta browse for it
um
sweet
all right let's duplicate this over here
this corner
awesome and i'm gonna just duplicate all
this stuff over
oh that's why okay so it just popped
into my sequencer on the right i
selected that window and it brought all
these windows in i think i just hit some
sort of hotkey to do that
i've noticed
that that i'll do that from time to time
it's really annoying
some sort of control shift
w
situation
all right
sweet
[Music]
that means this side is a little lower
huh
gosh dang it
sweet
and like i said we don't need
windows or not windows but uh columns we
technically don't need windows so i'll
probably just
ditch the windows here
go to our wide view
okay
ah
we're seeing under
underneath
uh ctrl shift g to ungroup let's bring
this
up just a little bit
cool
all right
so these windows let's see if we can't
start knocking out well let's take these
uh
oh is it does it
weird all right uh ctrl shift g
regroups everything
control
control shift g ungroups everything
and regroups everything interesting i
thought it was just for the objects you
had selected
um
easiest way to do this
all right let's type main glass
and get rid of all of these
everything that says main glass we will
hide
and
window glass
will do the same
awesome
dude this looks awesome heck yeah
this looks great
okay
just for
just because things are looking cool i'm
gonna bring our post process volume back
in
and
let's get the lighting a little bit more
toward what we're going for
what was it like
1875 or something
that's just night time
um
let's bring that sun back in
oh this looks great
geez
this looks really nice
cloud coverage uh one
[Music]
this looks this looks freaking awesome
wow okay
[Music]
maybe six
uh 1750
1800
[Music]
early morning looks cool though
[Music]
that almost looks fake
that's crazy
that looks awesome
um
the intensity
does a nice job here
this is where some like bloom and glow
would actually be nice
um let's see
fog a little bit of fog
always down for a little bit of fog
cloud cover uh
just an overcast foggy morning
[Music]
very early morning like
tweak this lighting
1750 maybe
zero cloud coverage
wow 1750s like
let's go wake up
um
1800 like right before the sun comes up
there's just
some starry night vibes here um
we could take
the intensity i don't know take the
intensity up
it's an interesting look
very interesting look
this is a blast to play with
um okay let's go to that post process
volume
and let's type bloom
and we want a little bit of it
all right that's obviously way too much
let's try convolution
a bit more accurate
1.5 is good
i can throw a vignette on it
but i still think this is too bright
it looks it looks really nice
but i think it's a little much um
let's go back to our ultra dynamic sky
and we'll bring
that time of day
i wonder if i brought
the sun around
1750
50
1700
1725
man it's all looking so good
17.75
wow that's intense let's take the
wow that is saturation at one okay the
intensity will just take to one
1750 or 1800
because i want to do some like night
city stuff in the background so i think
it's time to add
our cityscape business
all right
so let's hop out of this camera
pretty sweet okay
let's uh let's start playing with some
kit bash assets shall we
so
let us see what we got all right so kit
bash
um has a bunch of stuff
for unreal five i mean it's all fully
supported and unreal which is great
see if i can find it
kb 3d
we have our neo shanghai scene
i believe
it is
actors we want
there's lots of different
things to choose from here lots of
different buildings
yes
yes we want the
big buildings
building large
building large a what on earth
does that look like
my goodness
it is massive
it is loading
wow
wow
that is too cool
let's get it out there
that's so sick
um
let's push it way out there
get
go be gone broadway uh
way
out there
nice little city in the background here
amazing
so it'd be cool to have this whole thing
just kind of like
covered in city
dude that is out there
can't even click on it because of the
post-process volume
ah
all right
sweet okay
[Applause]
i wonder what would happen if we brought
back in
the switchboards if that would uh
block too much of our window
we could maybe have some
we probably don't need to have all of
them
i think some of them could help
but all of them that's a bit much
and you're asking is this scene on the
ground floor
yeah i believe it is but
we can lower all this stuff
and have it look like it's actually up
way up in the sky i think could be
pretty cool
but we'll get there we'll get there
i think the first thing we got to do is
just uh
duplicate a bunch of buildings around
and
build out the look we're going for it
would be cool to have buildings on all
sides but
maybe
let's start with like a landscape
perhaps
all right so we go to landscape mode
shift f2
and it's going to try and generate a
massive
landscape for us
i think that feels about right
let's go ahead and fill the world
i don't actually sorry i should have
done that
uh
let's try it again
doubling it every time
the 16 by 16. i just want it
to what it was before
uh
shoot
that i think is about right
something like this
hey
sweet all right so we have this massive
area we could paint
mountains and all this
all right
um
what is the quickest way to get some
mountains probably to use world creator
make a bunch of mountains and uh
and then have it be done
i had an open world creator in a minute
i don't even know if my license is still
active
all right there should be like a noise
mode here brush fall off brush type
noise here we go
let's see
noise we wanna
sculpt uh
i rarely use this stuff
brush size pretty large
all right whoa obviously
freaking crazy all right tool strength
point 1.01
and i think that's doing something
i can see it
yes
yep just a little bit
so i kind of just want to build up like
a little uh a ring
of like mountains around this area
all right we'll go point
103
wow that's still a lot geez okay 0.02
and that alone
should be looking like something um
all right
from here it looks like we need to come
up with that
adjust the camera speed
and let's just give ourselves a little
bit more uh
exposure here
matt g official tv yay i'm glad that you
found the old channel
thank you for joining
basically i think what we can do is we
can just like
let's get rid of that
control no okay that's all
hurting and we can erode
that
there we go um
we can take all of this
let's see we'll move
this whole landscape
up to the point where like
we can see what's going on
select the landscape again
raise it up
where we can actually see it
and then we'll go back in and actually
just
kind of punch a hole right in here so
we'll go back to the landscape mode
and we'll select sculpt
0.01
and
uh let's choose we want to push it in
[Music]
and to do that what is it control
or shift
shift we'll push it down
so i'm just making a big old divot
in here
so it's not blocking our stuff
hmm
doesn't look too hot
very subtle
extremely subtle
let's focus on the building placement
now
i got carried away with that landscape i
want maybe a little something like that
in the background but it could be nice
just to have buildings
because the buildings
only could mean that we are like way
high up on
in some building ourselves
let's see what else kit bash has
building b
[Music]
[Music]
loading loading loading
[Music]
all right here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna crank this camera speed way up i'm
gonna get out here
[Music]
and i'm just gonna kind of position
these buildings
start populating the scene and kind of
see what we're working with here
[Music]
i think giving it a ground floor as well
will be helpful
um
wow
okay
yeah this is at 13 we'll just call this
minus
1300 same deal here minus
thirteen hundred
sweet uh let's bring out
window place actors
let's bring out
a plane
we're gonna scale this thing way up
also bring it to negative 1300 this way
we can just place the buildings on this
plane
sweet
f will snap you to the objects all right
let's uh let's see what else they got
building c
amazing
large building d
these all as you can see like the first
time i brought this out
they take a minute to load but if you
bring it out before
the second time you bring it out they
load very quickly so that is awesome
building e
building f
building large g
h man it keeps going
i just
all right
media these are medium buildings here
these are our largest
too cool
i'm gonna have to figure out how to do
like a night
system
how that's gonna work but
you can open up these actors
or these blueprints rather
i have no idea like blueprints are
totally
totally um
foreign territory for me so
we can find glass
okay here's glass
black we can search for glass black okay
in the kit bash assets
we can open it up
go to
the parent which will be your master
material so we'll go in here this is the
master material material for the glass
and if i set
dude okay hold on
emissive color it does have a missive
club
wait a second
you're telling me
that
material instance already has
let's see materials
material instance already has emission
built in
what
oh multiply refraction opacity multiply
base color multiply
i'll multiply
all right let's check it again because i
feel like we're on to something here um
so the emissive color
i think it just needs to be turned into
a parameter
where are you emissive color boom right
here
right click convert to parameter and
we'll call this uh
emissive color
and we'll also
add something to this we're gonna hit m
s we'll call this emissive
um
intensity
i feel like we want intensity first
let's see yeah we want
where will this work
if i do that
missive intensity zero by default but if
we set it to 1
and we change this emissive color
great yeah that's gonna glow
and that is the intensity all right
amazing
so if we set it to black turns off
we'll save this
so now in the
material instance
we have this emissive color
and emissive intensity
and if we want to actually group it in a
more organized way
we can bring it back we can go to the
master material
we can select both
the intensity and the emissive color
pop it into a group
called
emission
save
close out and you should have it
you organize now into
emission yep up here
and we can turn on the intensity
and we can give it a color of say
something
orangish
and now these buildings
will probably be glowing yes
now
to take it a step further
i wonder
can we break up these windows
with some sort of noise
some checkered noise or even
some kind of material like
[Music]
what would be the best way to do this
so in theory
if we go to the master materials we go
to this glass black
and
yeah i should definitely like organize
this
we can take the emission this is what
we're working with here is the emission
i always like to be organized so you can
actually group these select it hit c and
call this
emission
we have base color
oh okay sweet metallic all that stuff
goes in here
that's nice
uh looks like this is our normal
[Music]
let's see
that's our normal
this looks like our
refraction up here
wow okay wow lots of stuff going on with
the refraction
quite a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
and we have our base
color
so for the emission if we instead of
just having a blanket
kind of uh
uniform across everything i think what
we can do
man that looks super cool though
i think what we can do is
break it up we want to break it up so it
looks like a night scene
and
the most ideal way to do this would be
to like
build out some sort of
black and white texture
or even a color texture
in photoshop or something or substance
whatever and pipe that into the
like as a lerp or something
in here now i don't exactly know
what we have a checker pattern
um
and this checker pattern if we
did this with a lerp if i hold l and
this pipes into
how would this work
how would this work exactly um
let's do
world position
oh boy that's intense
tiling we'd have to what multiply
the scalar parameter
set that to like
set it to one or something
100 1000
okay it's not multiplying with
uh
maybe i just pipe that into there
yeah
1.1
let's just see
if this is doing anything
for our mission
whoa
that is the most trippy
oh my god
what is the 0.01
uh
that's crazy looking um it's like every
other row
so you could just do that you can
multiply this with like a bunch or add
this to a bunch of different
materials or textures to get you a
different look
for
buildings at night but for now i think
we can keep it pretty simple i just
wanted to kind of demonstrate that i'm
going to be doing
a real in-depth version of that for the
final i believe
but for now we can stick with this
single material
and this is good
for now if we go
back to our scene
you see it's just a bit too much you
know
a little too much going on
and i'll just kind of position these
around
um
i think
probably what i'll do is just
go back to the glass turn off the
emission
those are the lights themselves
uh
glass black here we go
so we just leave them as is and we can
take the lights themselves
and crank them
base color yeah let's give this like a
warm
oh where is that or let's see
that's bright
all right i'll just kind of position
these guys around
and make different little clusters
building clusters
i love unreal engine man it's so fast
hmm
this group here we can grab all these
and just kind of position it rotate it
around
that's pretty sweet
yeah with the lights on it's gonna look
really nice
let's get these guys going
[Music]
and i wonder if i rotate the sky
if it'll actually reflect off of the
building glass and i think that
could be a pretty sweet look
so let me try and flip this ultra sky
around ultra dynamic sky
um
does it work like this can i just rotate
it
it doesn't appear so all right so let me
try um
let's try sun
the sun yes okay
it's an angle
there we go
let's do a full 180 on this thing
if we
see
all right these
these windows should reflect this thing
if i
start to pick this up a little bit
and you see it off the rooftops really
nicely
and what we could do is actually go into
the window master material
oh that's nice yeah so we go into the
window master material let's do that
glass black all right
and let's give it
metallic right is it has metallic it
seems
but
i'm going to get rid of that and make it
my own
and
basically just want to turn these things
chrome it will set the metallic to one
base color
so we can switch it right
we can actually say
you can do a switch parameter
and say uh
chrome question mark
and when you toggle chrome on so true
it starts uh false so it's not toggled
but if you check it on
it will basically let's see
false would be the current setup for
base color
true
would be
uh
true would be
a solid
i think a white solid
and specular we need specular
specular do we need specular
let's see
what is stopping this from doing its
thing roughness
i don't want to mess this thing up too
much
needs to be turned on
there we go there we go there we go i
just need to check the true box
i pipe this into metallic though
did we get
okay
i don't think we need specular
and then for this metallic i'll also do
another switcher
it's called a switch parameter
and this will be called
chrome
metallic
question mark
this is called
chrome
color question mark
this is kind of like a janky way to do
it but
uh false
is just default how it's currently set
up
true is
metallic one plugged in
and we want to set it to true default to
default to not true
and we right click we
these are already parameters that's good
i'm gonna grab this grab this
and put it in a group called
chrome
[Music]
and we'll save
and hopefully now when we go into
this material we can click
chrome color chrome metallic
check boxes yes and yes
which turns it metallic
which then reflects the light the
sunlight properly
yeah
i won't say properly i'll just say
it reflects it more so
alright so now when we're back in our
scene
we should be getting some light from the
sunlight
and if i were to go ahead and uh
get that sunlight back to
1750
1800
and then turned up the intensity
to like five
you're going to start to see a little
bit of
that reflected in those buildings
and i think the more we actually rotate
this thing
oh man then we had ray trace reflections
shoot this is dangerous territory
post-process volume we can turn it on
and we'll go to
reflection
method
ray traced
oh interesting
so it looks like this glass
hmm
it's like going through
i think it needs
it's transparent
uh it's because it's transparent we
don't want it to be transparent
um
in this case so we need to set up
so the opacity
ah okay there's actually a switcher for
that
where are you where are you where are
you glass black yeah let's set the
opacity
multiplier to one
fraction blend
five
so i don't wanna i don't wanna jack
things up too much here
yeah you see that you see you're still
seeing through this thing even though
it's
no metallic so i think there's some sort
of see-through thing that's probably
just the opacity
but this isn't doing anything
for some reason
[Music]
it's a small thing that
i think i'm just going to dive into in
detail a little bit later
i don't know if i need to go this far
currently
but if we
rotate
the position of the sky
we search for sun
i think we had set that to 180 sun angle
yeah we can start moving this around
and catch a bit more
reflection on those buildings
it's kind of a way to like cheat the
lights a little bit i have to figure out
the opacity thing if i want to
get it looking
just right but
it's not too bad
not too bad just to kind of like work in
this look here
oh
man i've been
in it
how are y'all doing
you guys have any questions we've been
at it for a minute here
um i'm down to take a little little mini
break and then
maybe hop back in for just a touch more
but
i pretty much did everything i set out
to do we could maybe open up some of
these windows here or something
maybe drop in
i'll have to figure out the glass stuff
yeah that's just going to be tutorial
town i'm not going to put you all
through that
brand doom yo i've been watching your
videos throughout my art studies and
just graduated congratulations on your
graduation
that's awesome brandon
thanks for inspiration and keep up the
awesome work absolutely man thank you
for the support thank you all for
the continued support and uh coming back
here and watching these we got one more
week left on the 3d challenge here
we're gonna see hundreds thousands i
will say thousands of submissions come
in here over this last week
so it's going to be incredible
i really wish you all the best of luck
here on the
on this last week
definitely try and
not push it to the end get a version out
as fast as you can so you at least have
something
um and then we'll go from there
basically tweak add little tweaks where
you can so for me i'm pretty much just
gonna get these buildings all set
and then i'm going to
make sure that my character i'm going to
get the character all hooked up
this week because if without the
character there's no render so i got to
get them looking good from there
once my character is nice and solid and
i have a version rendered out
then i can go back in and start adding
little tweaks here and there where i
feel it's necessary
ah
was it been like three hours or so three
and a half hours
yeah i'll probably go back in for just a
little bit more but
i feel like it might end it a little
early
today um
let's see
why don't i use metahuman instead of
dazz because metahuman does not give me
uh the amount of control that i want
i want a very specific character
i want to be able to do cloth
simulations i need a naked character
essentially so that i can do cloth
simulations over that character
and i'm not
as far as i believe the meta human
workflow
only gives you
a handful of clothes
um
and i'm sure you can get a bunch of
different looks and stuff but
yeah i found that the daz workflow
was best for what i was trying to do
specifically in this case
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's looking a little bright here
uh one second y'all two seconds here
there we go let's turn down this
brightness
that's a little bit better
nice
um
you guys have any questions i am down to
answer let's do a little q a right now
before we call it
if you hit me with the at punisher
in the live chat i can uh see it a
little bit more clearly
yeah i've really been enjoying this
process i'm
very happy with the art that i've put
out so far or i hadn't put it out but
i'm happy with how it's going i hope
you're all feeling good about your art
as well
um
it really makes me want to do
a challenge that doesn't involve
characters because
so much of my struggle was in the
character side of things this time
around it'd be nice to do
i don't know any number of something
that isn't a character based thing
so we'll see
you know we're always trying to switch
it up with these challenges every time
we do one so
maybe this next one we get uh we get
real unique with it we'll see we'll do
some brainstorming on it
um
fly guy flea guy what kind of work do
you mostly do nowadays i
full-time work on this channel all my
work is based
is just doing videos making videos
um
educational 3d videos for everybody
creating art doing breakdowns on the art
that is all the work i do i don't do
freelance work i don't do part-time work
at one place or another
it's literally this youtube channel
there's the patreon which helps out
i sell a very small amount of assets
separate of course those are included in
the patreon
um
and then you know
ad integrations on youtube is a there's
a big chunk of it
um the views
on youtube alone aren't enough aren't a
fraction of enough to pay the bills
um but it's doing the brand deals and
the integrations
that um that really helped me
live
and
do youtube full time so when i do say
you know click the link in the
description i try not to push it too
hard and all that stuff
i know you guys don't like being
advertised too and you're advertised to
24 7. i really
i really don't like it i i don't like
being advertised to all the time um
again which is why i try and
structure
the brands on this channel the
integrations on this channel as much as
i can
specifically to first off what what i
like
and i think if i keep it personal and
and uh unique to me then it'll be a
little bit more unique to you i try and
keep it as genuine as possible
um
so yeah that that's work for me these
days uh working on the movie writing a
movie
and then trying to take some free time
to myself as well like rock rock
climbing yesterday that was great
get getting back into it
um
blame it is awesome
seeing you go from a box to a beautiful
scene good job thank you thank you
will all right your background is just
2d you're a fashion designer that wants
to start working with 3d
what program might be best for a
beginner or beginner that is
a program that is great for clothing and
flow ability
well i know that uh
marvelous designer is a pretty amazing
program and maybe one of the best when
it comes to
doing uh
clothing
i think it was made for designing
clothing first and foremost
and then
you know people like myself well i
haven't picked it up yet but
people like myself have picked it up to
include it as a 3d simulation for
their clothing and whatnot
so that's a great program
but if you're trying to get into 3d i
would say blender is probably the
fastest way to do so it's free
um it's powerful
you can do a lot of stuff there's a lot
of tutorials for it
um i myself use cinema 4d but you know
teach their own
and unreal engine is also free it's
pretty much it's a pretty deep dive but
it's definitely doable it's possible
as do you see here on the streams
you can go back to the first stream
where i used unreal engine
pretty crazy
uh re-illusion released a free auto
rigger this week could be a game changer
that is good to know very good to know
auto rigging is is very tricky
you're taking a base mesh and you're
giving it bones so that you can move it
and animate it and for me
anytime i auto rig or do auto weights
weights basically means if i if i um
move this finger here
then the middle if if i'm just trying to
move my index finger
but it's also pulling on my middle
finger
and then your then your weights are off
you need to paint the weights better
you need to unpaint the weights
here so it's colors like if if the
finger is red
the middle finger should be yellow that
way when you move red it doesn't move
yellow but you see how my middle finger
is kind of moving a little bit
it would have a little bit of red in it
right so that's painting weights
you can move your finger and your head
will dip down like that that's because
your weights are all jacked up so the
auto rigging auto weight stuff
is always tough for me because it never
quite does it right
um and it always comes down to just the
manual process but
i hadn't discussed
i am not the one to talk about character
workflows all alright it is a dark it is
darkness for me all right and i'm trying
to figure it out as well
um
how hard has it been to avoid the
temptation and looking at the discord
and everyone's works in progress that
are sharing there i don't need to stop
myself i can definitely look
i could look there any time um
i love it i love looking at the
submission form actually seeing the
final renders come in is amazing
um and then yeah hanging out in the
discussion channel is cool too seeing
all your guys works in progress it
really is the best part of the challenge
having everyone's work come in having
the music come in
uh and bringing it all together is just
the absolute best
how long have i been using unreal just
about two years now just a little under
two years
you want to learn it but your pc can't
run it um
have you tried with unreal five
give it a shot
um it's pretty powerful and it's
i hear i mean i you know i
this is my full-time job i have a pretty
beefed up rig at this point um so i
can't say it should work for everybody
um i understand but give unreal five a
shot see if it if it's not a little
easier on you maybe you tried four and
it was a little chunky five they're
doing a lot of things with nanite to
make it a lot more
performance capable
see any other questions y'all
why do i use a pen instead of a mouse
great question many of you know the
answer to this um so
you know i have a mouse here
there's technically i have two two
computers my old computer this is the
new one from puget my old one that i
built while i was at rocket jump
uh with my buddy danny
that old computer is the stream machine
now so
um
sonamonte basically parsecs into it and
all of the stuff that you're seeing here
my computer my display
my camera
all that stuff is plugged into my stream
machine so i'm able to download stuff
i'm able to you know um
i don't have to worry about worry about
bandwidth
my the stream is separate from the work
i'm doing but the work is piped into the
stream
very long
long winded days i got d real quick
i have a mouse for that it's the only
reason i have this mouse um is so i can
quickly just mouse over let soda monte
in and then
that's all i use the computer for um
the wacom tablet this thing is great
because you know it's
you know it's all wired up
but you all know it's part of the
challenge here they actually wacom has
two days left for their
their sale they have an intuos pro sale
the link is also in the description this
one's just shout outs to wacom i don't
get anything for this that's totally
fine i just love them i love what they
do they're giving uh
you know
money off on small medium and large pro
tablets into those pro tablets but these
things are great
i was turned on to them uh by a friend
who worked on the marvel title sequences
over at rocket jump
and
uh you know he was like it's just so
much better it saves your wrist
from any carpal tunnel or injury that
you would have from a mouse
and just that alone was pretty much all
i needed to hear because i want to be
able to do this for a long time
and
being as healthy as possible is very
very important to me
so that was reason number one um reason
number two was it would make uh painting
in photoshop drawing a lot easier i love
i love drawing so
that was a hobby for me but then at a
certain point i'm like
i can use the tablet for everything
so
you know i do everything short of play
pc games with it some pc games you can
play with it
um but i don't play too many pc games at
this point anymore mostly playstation
and switch
um
so that that's the pen the pen tablet
the intuos pro
um
love those things
any other questions i'm looking at the
at punishers here uh
see cody thank you this is an old school
old school shirt
it's chipping away
this is a very this is a prized shirt
only has a few more washes left
trevor
are you handling the burnout better
these days you were pretty stressed out
a while back after leaving corridor
yes i am handling it so much better
um for a couple reasons
one i was putting out a video every
single week and that was killing me um
i was streaming every single week
and on top of that i was trying to make
videos like art breakdowns and run
challenges and all this and that
um
at the same time
and i
am very ambitious i bite off a lot more
than i can chew and about a year ago
i kind of maxed out i put out a whole
video on it too
it's called uh
what the heck is it called it's called
snacks why we can't live off of snacks
i want to do bigger
bigger projects
and
crunching so hard every single week to
do these little bite sizes oh i just got
to make the week oh what the heck am i
gonna do i had no time to think after
streaming on saturday i'm like ugh i'm
done until monday and i'm like oh shoot
what am i gonna do for this week's
stream no and it was very stressful
so i switched to
a video
once every
uh two weeks so two videos a month
switching that schedule was great so
that's one stream a month and
one uh pre-edited
packaged video a month obviously the
challenge months are a little bit
different
i like to stream with you guys every
single weekend on my piece of art to
support you and
there's no other time to get this work
done then on the weekends so it seems at
some point but uh or sometimes it seems
that way
so that was one is going to uh two
videos every month the other was trying
to find help
um so getting sodamonte to join me here
for these streams and help me out as a
stream producer and run things behind
the scenes and get the streams set up is
a huge help
um
so shout outs to usoto
um and
also getting an editor too finding an
editor
was a big one
um they can help me cut the brand
integrations they can help me cut um
you know the big videos that i do as
well
so that is huge that is
that is
the best really
that gives me time to work on my movie
to write the movie it gives me time to
take a break and enjoy myself
um and take the breaks that i need in
order to be able to come here and work
to the best of my ability
so those two things getting help
um
and not pushing myself as hard
and you know what it's funny because
like uh
if you watch the video when i left
corridor
sam nico and reni each gave me a piece
of advice
and both of those things that i did to
make my life a little bit better are
directly from their advice which is
crazy
nico said
live your life it's not all about work
and ren said
uh
never uh what'd he say he said you can
always ask for help
and those two things
amazing
sam sam's piece of advice said
sometimes you just gotta put it out you
just gotta put the video out even if
it's not up to what you want
it's time to just let it go and move on
um and that's been helpful for me
throughout you know all three of their
pieces of advice have been amazing
um
what else y'all i think that's that's
about it
that is about it i think with that i'm
gonna head out y'all i'm gonna you know
um
join my wife here she's at a friend's a
baby shower so we're gonna hit that up
i'm gonna go to the park and join me
some food
thank you all so much for for joining me
um
this is the last week it's a big week
for all of us
hang in there
get a version that you can submit
rendered asap
and then
at least you'll have something
to submit when it comes to the
challenges
and then spend the rest of your time
just tweaking and making it better
making it better making it better
alright so get that render out
solve all the glitches
then from that point you have a passable
render to submit and then make it a
little bit better day by day i'm gonna
be doing that
um this week starting with the character
getting my character solid
knocking it out
not working on any more environment i'm
not touching the environment
until i get that character solid and
then i'm gonna do a render and then i
can tweak and do some details so that's
what i'll be doing
um
monday
we will have a little town hall meeting
on the discord server so definitely
don't miss that we'll be talking you to
you guys bringing you up onto the stage
chatting for five minutes per person
about the challenge what it was like for
yourself how you enjoyed it what you're
still working on what you look maybe for
the next challenge maybe getting some
ideas with the next challenge um so i'd
love to hear from you all that's going
to be monday at i believe
noon
is when we usually do it
that's pacific standard time
if you're on the discord server there's
an event it's already up there
top left so
just take note
actually no i lied it's not up there but
it will be up there noon psd on monday
okay be there
um
i think that's everything y'all if
there's any more kit bash codes left
there's only 50 when we started the
stream uh 30 off meditation 30 is the
code you all want to get yourself some
kit bash kits they are the best we'll be
giving away
more um one week from now
on the very final stream we'll be doing
we'll be giving away some more kit bash
codes
um
yeah check out wacom they got their sale
popping off if you guys are trying to
buy a an intuos pro tablet i love them
they've helped me out
kept my wrists safe
they're running that for two more days
you know
good luck good luck
for the rest of the week i'll see you
guys uh in the server i'll see you on
that town hall meeting on monday
and um
i'll see you back here on saturday for
the final stream y'all the final one so
have a good one much love to you guys
thank you for joining me have a great
weekend peace out y'all later
[Music]
ten
[Music]
you